ha estado pidiendo refuerzos desde el
comienzo de la invasión el pentágono
confirmó el martes por la noche que se
entregaron los aviones de combate y las
piezas de repuesto solicitadas durante
mucho tiempo por el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski pero se negó a
comentar sobre la cantidad o el origen
me gustaría decir sin entrar en lo que
otras naciones están proporcionando que
ellos han recibido plataformas y piezas
adicionales para poder aumentar el
tamaño de su flota el tamaño de su flota
de aviones creo que lo dejaría así
en plataformas y partes una plataforma
es un avión en este caso han recibido
aviones adicionales y partes de aviones
para ayudarlos a poner más aviones en el
aire diría que ciertamente hemos ayudado
con el transbordo de algunas piezas de
repuesto adicionales que han ayudado con
las necesidades de sus aviones pero no
hemos transportado aviones completos
sin nombrar ningún país donante ni
detalle sugirió que el equipo podría
involucrar aviones mig-29 esto luego de
que pidiera ayuda a sus aliados
occidentales para proporcionar aviones
fabricados en rusia que sus pilotos ya
saben cómo operar y que algunas naciones
de europa del este ya tienen
síndic cuanto más y antes obtengamos
todas las armas que hemos solicitado más
fuerte será nuestra posición y antes
ahora paz o si el anuncio se produce una
semana después de que el presidente de
byd en revelará un paquete de ayuda
militar de 800 millones de dólares para
ucrania y sugiere un cambio en las
actitudes occidentales luego de evadir
inicialmente el suministro directo de
armas y que moscú dijera que
consideraría estas acciones como una
participación en la guerra